In this problem, a train traveling over
a bridge suffers an accident that causes
one of the attached rail cars to rupture
and spill 10,000 gallons of a
contaminant into a river below.
The contaminant data is as follows.
The oral reference dose is 0.008
mg over kg * days.
The inhalation reference dose is 0.15 mg
over kg * days.
The inhalation rate for a child is 0.46
cubic meters per hour.
The half-life is 5 days.
The biodegradation
K constant
for first-order decay is 0.14 days to
the minus one.
The town downstream of the spill is
preparing to treat the water coming from
this river to bring the contaminant to
an acceptable concentration.
Assuming a 6-month exposure duration and
complete bodily absorption,
determine the maximum allowable
contaminant concentration in drinking
water such that a 15-kg child consuming
1.5 L per day does not exceed the
reference dose.
So, this problem looks long, but almost
everything in it is a distraction. You
only need three numbers.
So, we're solving for the maximum
contaminant concentration in drinking
water in milligrams per liter such that
a child does not exceed the oral
reference dose.
So, this is a drinking water plus
ingestion plus reference dose problem.
So, first let's filter out what we don't
need from this problem.
The information up top, most of it is
meant to distract you.
We don't need the 10,000 gallons.
We don't need the inhalation reference
dose since we're talking about drinking
water ingestion.
We don't need the inhalation rate.
We don't need the half-life.
And we don't need the biodegradation
factor.
Six months we may or may not need
depending on how you solve this problem,
so we'll keep it for now.
All the other terms are for air exposure
or fate and transport, which are not
needed here.
So let's solve this using method one.
So if we were to search the reference
manual for reference dose, there are at
least two equations that we could use to
solve this problem. One is a derivation
of the other.
We can start with the equation for
ingestion in drinking water as it's
longer and it might be the first
equation that you are inclined to try to
use.
So here,
CDI
equals
CW
times
IR
E
F
times ED
over
BW
times
AT.
And here, the chronic daily intake or
CDI is actually going to be equal to our
reference dose.
So we will set CDI to RFD
for a safe exposure limit. Now we can
start filling in our knowns and our
unknowns.
So our CDI is going to be our reference
dose, which is given here
as 0.008
mg over kg day.
And this is going to be equal
to the chemical concentration in water,
CW.
This is going to be our unknown.
So, CW W
times the ingestion rate given here is
going to be 1.5 L per day.
times our exposure frequency
which is our days per year rate, not to
be confused with the number of days
actually studied. So, in this case, even
though it's a 6-month period, the rate
is daily or
days per year.
And then our exposure duration ED, this
is going to be a duration
given years. So, 6 months is going to be
0.5
years.
On the bottom of this equation,
we have our body weight, which for a
child is 15 kg given here.
And
our AT is going to be another duration
also equal to half a year. AT is given
as the averaging time in days. So,
again, instead of 6 months, we are going
to do 365 over 2.
So, just to clarify, rate,
duration,
and
duration.
And these are the same period in this
type of non-cancer problem.
So, if we simplify this equation out,
we can see that all of our time
components over here cancel out to one.
Leaving us with liters per day,
kilograms, and milligrams over kilogram
day.
So, CW is going to solve very easily
down to 0.08
mg/L,
which would be our third answer over
here.
Now, once you've solved out this
equation, you might notice that it looks
very similar to another one
already given in the reference manual.
So, if we were reading this problem for
the first time,
and again saw that this was focused on
just drinking water ingestion and the
reference dose,
we could have skipped to using a
derivation of the full equation and
solved directly for the drinking water
equivalent level.
Also present in our reference manual,
the DWEL equation is given as
D W E L equals
reference dose
times body weight
over Q,
where Q is the daily water consumption
in liters per day.
So, this time the maximum allowable
contaminant concentration would be our
drinking water equivalent level.
And these terms are provided directly by
the problem. We can also notice
that those are the same exact terms here
as would be given here.
So, let's solve this out.
Again, our reference dose is 0.008
mg over kilogram day.
Our body weight is going to be
15 kilograms,
and our ingestion rate is going to be
1.5
liters per day.
The same numbers
end up coming out here
and giving us a final answer of 0.08
mg/L.
So, a couple key takeaways,
if you see the reference dose and
drinking water,
you might want to try to remember to
think in terms of DWEL, so you don't
have to subject yourself to a slightly
longer equation set up.
If the exposure is daily,
and you do set it up this way, you can
remember that the EF, ED, and AT terms
will cancel.
And if your answer is in mg per liter,
your ingestion rate is probably going to
be in liters per day.
So, a problem like this, don't let all
the extra data trick you.
This can be a one equation problem if
you know exactly what you're solving
for.
And that's it.